Turkey and Russia have launched join
ground patrols in northeastern Syria the
operation is part of a deal struck by
the countries to end turkeys offensive
against Kurdish militia and the border
region and removed the Kurdish fighters
from the area the patrols will begin or
within a 10-kilometer zone along the
border the steps immense the power shift
in Syria a month
after President Donald Trump withdrew US
forces from there for more on I joined
by our correspondent Yulia Hahn in
Istanbul you live what are these patrols
all about well the deal struck there
between Ankara and Moscow last week
provided for the withdrawal of Syrian
Kurdish fighters some 30 kilometers from
the Turkish border Ankara considers
these fighters terrorists with the links
to the local PKK insurgency
so the withdrawal was the Turkish
government's condition for pausing it's
a deadly offensive there in northern
Syria now Russia said some 34,000
fighters have indeed left the area but
Turkey wants to use these joint patrols
to confirm this in president Aaron has
repeatedly threatened in the past days
to restart this military operation if
deemed necessary and Iulia Syrian
President Bashar al-assad has been
talking about Turkish Russian
cooperation let's first take a listen to
what he said on a syrian state TV this
agreement is a positive step
it does not achieve everything in the
sense that it will not pressure the
Turks to leave immediately however it
limits the damage and paves the way for
the liberation of this region in the
future or the immediate future as we
hope so yulia assad is sounding very
upbeat there what do you make of his
comments well yes it appears Assad feels
like he's the big winner after
everything we saw happening there in
northern Syria since early October since
US President Trump and now
the withdrawal of American troops from
the area as we know after turkey started
its military operation the Kurds have
turned to the Syrian regime and its most
powerful ally Russia for help against
the Turkish attacks and this in turn
allowed Bashar lasat to swiftly deploy
forces and reclaim territory there in
northern Syria where he didn't have a
foothold in many years now the Kurds in
the area are still somehow hoping for a
political solution for some kind of
self-rule deal with the Syrian regime
but yesterday in his speech Bashar
al-assad said that he aims to restore
state authority over the Kurdish control
areas so for him overall this is a huge
step towards winning the Syrian war
there and that's why expectations are
very low that the Syrian regime will
make any concession concessions for
example in Geneva where currently we
have talks going on about a new Syrian
Constitution brokered by the United
Nations not the UN secretary-general
Guterres mehta turkish President Recep
tibe at dawn today what did they talk
about well nothing has emerged yet
publicly from this meeting but we know
that touch president add one wanted to
talk with Qataris about his plans for
establishing what he calls as a safe
zone there in northern Syria this is one
of the main objectives of turkeys
military operation Aaron wants to
resettle many of the 4.6 million Syrian
refugees currently living here in Turkey
to this area he wants to build houses
schools police stations hospitals so
whole cities basically and this is of
course a very costly project state media
here in Turkey have reported an
estimated 26 billion u.s. dollars at
least this would would cost so Aaron was
going to ask a terrace for setting up an
international donors conference because
he can't pay for it alone the question
is would the UN really get on board
because these so-called safe zone plans
have risk
a lot of criticism internationally
outside of Turkey some say this is
Turkey trying to occupy parts of
northern Syria of Syria or trying to
change the demographics of this area and
then of course the big question is what
do Syrian refugees themselves say what
they voluntary voluntarily return to
this area Yulia Hahn in the Turkish city
of Istanbul thank you very much for that